pour incontournable de la scène
alternative les mieux en mieux celle de
sortir un nouvel album choisir le chat
il vien de nou d'ouvéa leur studio de
répétition démonstration
mais m
25 ans d'engagement est toujours là pour
porter le discours de ceux qu'on
n'entend plus
avec la belle voix rauque de pierre
c'est la voix des sans voix c'est à dire
des gens qu'on n'entend pas forcément
les gens qui sont l'eau les gens qui
sont la partie immergée de l'iceberg
qui ont les soucis et dont on n'entendra
jamais parlé aux gens qui savent pas
souvent mais j'en compte pas la grande
gueule
je
moi ça me saoule leur histoire de
religion ça me je ne crois pas je crois
pas en dieu je crois pas au père noël et
là j'ai l'impression tous les jours on
voudrait nous faire croire que enfin il
ya des mecs qui sont avait invité sur
des chaînes de télé pour parler du père
noël alors il y en a qui ont un père
noël vert de temps un père noël rouge de
mon père noël noir ils sont pas d'accord
sur leur leurs trucs pour les îles pas
de métaphores l'epr ning vont droit au
but quand il dénonce l'utilisation de
rejet polluant dans le bitume
à la fin ce qui reste quand on a
récupéré ce qu'on voulait il reste un
sable qui s'appelle le stérile et ce
sable en fête a été donnée est utilisé
partout en france pour fabriquer des
routes des bâtiments des départs que
nous tous que qui a besoin de ça pour
faire du ciment et du béton donc c'est
bien c'est un truc hautement contrat fin
c'est que ces contaminés à l'uranium 335
je ne sais combien
donc voilà ce genre de choses là nous
touche un petit peu
sensible à la cause antinucléaire le
groupe s'implique pour le japon et
mobilise ses fans mardi prochain hôte
108 pour soutenir un projet de
reconstruction de salles de concert
avec le nucléaire les japonais ils ont
jamais eu de pot
j'en ai rien à
par contre si julien lepers s'arrête
questions pour un champion
ça fait ch et didier super as montlouis
ça ne se rate pas
y'aura avec la dame blanche la choriste
de sergent garcia
l'artiste cubaine jouera ce soir à
anglet
les agences néerlandaise nox et au n
elles sont à l'honneur à amis
des formes fluides et évolutive sans
angle droit évoque les cta liquide
ici comme un poisson échoué le pavillon
de l'eau douce au total ce sont une
dizaine d'oeuvres issues de la
collection du frac l'exposition
s'intitule au fil de l'eau
et on referme cet agenda avec un petit
jeune
mais
slow joe un poète indien de 71 ans ce
sera au quart de tour mardi soir
mario
justement sur la plaine de la gloriette
nous y serons mais l'agenda continue on
se retrouve dans 15 jours